[Music]
we're gonna go to mark in um idaho falls
um it's important as we're um mark you
there
yeah i'm here hey man so i'm gonna set
the stage here
recently had your wife andy on the show
and correct um
she talked about working through
um
the discovery that uh the father of um
somebody close to you
had sexually assaulted and sexually
abused your
young teenage daughter
and one of the she was 11 at the time
she 11th time okay
oh man so one of the
one of the things when we were talking
she mentioned was that her husband uh
you was really
struggling with rage
and i don't know if you remember the
call if you listen to it i don't know if
it's out yet
um
but
i am the daughter i mean i'm the father
of a 12 year old and a six-year-old
little girl
and i felt my body
reacting to that call and i said man if
you have your have your husband call me
and here you are man you're a brave
brave man
um so just starting out of the gate i
want to thank you for calling and um
let's work this one together man so tell
me what's going on
well i'll do my best to try to contain
my crap um hey this is
a we've got great editors on this show
and b
i'm
by far the most full crap person here so
you let it run man
well some some other things have come to
light since
my wife had spoken with you but i guess
my question is is
and i i had to write it down um you're
trying to just contain emotions and
stuff but how do i a loving father of
five amazing daughters handle my hatred
and rage
towards this evil person
and at the same time try to keep my
composure
and put on a happy face for my family
um
yeah that's kind of where i'm struggling
and then to
kind of add more to it so my my daughter
that we've found this out about
um you know
she's been in counseling and everything
else but very recently um
we found out that she is being
victimized online by other men who are
sending her videos and
and what have you i've since been taking
control of of it all but this just adds
to my anger and to my hatred
um
you know i'm i'm
in front of my family i'm pretty calm
and collective and and i i hold my stuff
together pretty well but when
i find myself just kind of alone my uh
my mind tends to wander and
and the rage and hatred and anger come
out very very quickly um
i'm a pretty active guy i'm involved
heavily with jiu jitsu and mixed martial
arts and
and other physical things and it seems
like those kind of curb
um the anger although i do feel sorry
for some of my my counterparts that i i
do these things on but
i find myself just kind of in the
recesses of myself i
it's very very close to the surface and
if any time i even bring up just
slightly
this stuff that just it the hatred anger
just overtake me yeah
yeah
and i think any
any mother any father listening to this
um i would say especially the fathers
just because i am one
i mean i i can't imagine somebody
experiencing what you're experiencing
and have experienced and not feeling the
exact same way
i'll tell you this is the single hardest
call
i've ever had to make
um i've ever been a part of all the
calls about violence all the calls about
this is the hardest one and jenna and
kelly let me know this one was coming
and like you i actually made some notes
too um
because i'm gonna get emotional okay
so i want you to think less about like
i'm some guy with all the answers as and
more than
um i'm a fellow mixed martial arts guy
too and we're just a couple of dads
sitting down trying to figure out what
happens next okay
yeah is that cool
so i want you to interrupt me and stop
me at any time because i can get to
preaching a little bit um and tell me if
i'm out of bounds ever okay
okay
i'm also gonna promise as hard as it is
i'm gonna tell you the truth is that
cool
yeah
and if at any point you get pissed off
at me that is completely okay all right
first thing here is your anger and your
rage are right
it's your body responding to the deepest
and most primal
violation that i can imagine
okay
so i don't want you to think that you're
crazy or that you're nuts or something's
broken inside of you it is not
okay
can you tell me about the rage
um
how does it come over you
it's just i guess
kind of like a tsunami where i get these
moments where just randomly and i guess
i could kind of liken it a little bit to
what i would imagine like
ptsd would feel like to a certain extent
where
i'll just be driving to work or in a
store or it tends to be kind of when i'm
by myself and i have my thoughts to
myself
and it just kind of overcomes me where
i just feel this just rage and that's
probably the best word for it where
you know i haven't done anything to this
individual i've made promises not to
um
is this person in jail
no so uh
last we're aware of it's all under a
investigation yeah and they can't share
anything else with me at this point um
it sounds like maybe some other victims
maybe have come through which is almost
always
my daughter because my daughter does not
want to be the first person to
talk or do a forensic interview or any
of that
i think what
bothers me probably just as much too is
you know i have a bit of a law
enforcement background as well so i know
how long these proceedings can
take yep um
and so to kind of answer your question
it just it seems like
when i'm by myself and just kind of
loaned to my thoughts i just
i fantasized about hurting this person
like i
i want to
i want to see this person's world just
burn
and i want to see his family watch it
burn in front of him yep because that's
what he did to me
i want to be there to see it and smile
because
i've never hated someone so much and so
bad of course as i do this individual
and
for
legal sakes and everything else i feel
like i can't do anything about it
i can't do anything not for legal sex
we'll get down
because what
because then my family loses me there
you go
that's right
so this is beyond anger and this rage
the word i usually associate with rage
is trapped
and you just explained it perfectly
you your body is saying do this thing
and the fantasies the pictures you're
creating in your head about what this
thing would feel like and look like and
be like
is powerful
and also there's the reality
you've kept up with the cane velasquez
thing probably like
you see the other side of that
and i know i know this doesn't make
logical sense as well but there is so
much guilt that i feel because i'm the
one that dropped my daughter off hold on
hold on that's it that's it that's it
you're not trapped in this rage cycle my
brother
you're trapped in shame
because you feel like this happened on
your watch
and you feel like you should have been
able to do something to protect your
precious little girl and you're trapped
in an imaginary failure
and you may have even had some feelings
that this dude was a scumbag you may
have even felt that
or you're you know maybe not maybe not
but there's always that like
there was a prompting i i felt like
there was a prompting about this guy
that's right you and so
now what you've done is you're trapped
in these recurring thoughts and you wake
up and the adrenaline and the cortisol
that you have harnessed over years of
law enforcement stuff and jiu-jitsu
training you know what happens next and
you know that and your body's primed for
it
and
you keep looping back as though you can
go back and edit what has happened
and here's the worst thing i can tell
you
it happened
and there's a period at the end of that
sentence
there is not a single thing you can do
to stop what happened from happening
because it already happened
and until you grieve the absolute bloody
hell out of that
your body will continue to piece up and
piece up and spin up and ready to roll
and get ready to roll over and over and
over again to try to solve a problem
that can't be solved backwards
and i'm telling you this as a guy who's
got a very similar background to you
who's got a little girl
and i told kelly the reason this call
was going to be hard for me because i'm
telling you things that i wouldn't want
to hear
right
yeah
and when we get trapped and we get
enraged
the switch that gets flipped
is our ego
becomes about revenge about getting even
and you are chugging poison every day
and you're spraying it across your
family like a lawn fertilizer spreader
and you're hoping that dude will die and
he will not
just you
so let me tell you this as directly as i
can
this man's
to pulse through your veins creating
distance between you and your wife and
your daughters and your community
then you are voluntarily handing this
man everything these girls have left
don't do that
is that fair
yeah
do not give him this
he's taken enough
your anger and rage is not about her and
it's not about him it's about you and
you my brother have to forgive you
this is not your fault
like i said i
i know logically that makes sense but
you have to say the words i forgive you
mark
i don't know if i'm there yet i know but
you got to
and
again i'm piling it up on you now
but you think you're covering it up at
home
my guess is you're a nuclear reactor
because what's happening now is your
daughter has become a project she's
become somebody to heal someone
something to solve something to get
better she's become a picture and a
frame
right a cause to take to the streets for
and what she really needs is to be your
daughter
and you are a nuclear reactor right now
and so you're good enough and you're
disciplined enough
you've worked your ass off to become
super disciplined so that you can
control yourself in hard moments
but the inside of you is on fire and
children are particularly attuned to
that electricity
and so this is the hardest thing i'm
i mean the second hardest thing i'm
gonna tell you
you've gotta decide i'm gonna set this
thing down
and i wish it was harder than that
and i wish it was more complex than that
but you have to make a series of
behavioral choices to stop this
yeah because the rage is gonna kill you
and the rage is gonna take
these five beautiful wonderful daughters
daddy from them
and there's a reason why when this
happens often it breaks up families
because somebody's not grieving enough
somebody's grieving too much somebody's
too angry someone's not angry enough
this will blow your marriage up if
you're not careful
yeah
yeah it's already caused some amount of
stress yeah it has and hey all that's
normal man that's totally normal
y'all aren't crazy you're not busted up
i mean this is a mess and the the awful
part about this is it will ricochet
through right once that switch is
flipped and once that darkness is open
especially in a pre-pubescent teen
entering into being a teenager
um
yeah man it's a rabbit hole now you just
found
down the rabbit hole even further right
yeah
this thing will have consequences and
cascades throughout
and it's a decision a daily decision to
handle and deal with and work through
and heal
those things as they happen
and not to continue like every time
every time
like especially recently as i've taken
away my daughter's phone and seen some
of the conversations with some of the
pictures that people have sent her
online
it's enraged it brings everything so
close to the surface again that it just
i we live it over and over and over
again
and in this sense
and in a way to try to protect
my wife too i
she's aware of these but
i refuse to let her see any of these
vivid images
that i've had to see and endure over the
last couple of days right
is it does it benefit you
to see that stuff
no but it's too late i've already seen
it
i know
but now you've got it you've got a
choice moving into the future
when someone says we've seen we found
some things on your daughter's computer
at school or we have found some things
on a friend's computer
you now know
um
i don't need to see that tell me what it
is
i'm good
and can i tell you this we often um when
things happen to our kids
our brain replays those things as though
they are happening again in real time
okay so conversation we have with folks
who
lose a child in a car wreck
is one of the one of the keys to healing
is recognizing
that kid experienced a moment of terror
or maybe a moment of intense pain
as the car wreck happened
but now that kid is not hurting
you see what i'm saying
yeah
and
your daughter experienced some dark dark
evil
fear
terror paralyzed
and right now she's safe in your home
and she's got a mom and a dad who love
her
see what i'm saying she's still hurting
and she's still hurt and she's got
healing to go
but it's so easy to go back to she's
still on that in that moment and she's
not right now
okay
yeah
i will tell you as a guy who tries to
out weightlift and out shoot and out run
and out train and out learn new things
my
hurts
the only way through this is grief
[Music]
yeah i feel like i can't outrun this you
cannot i promise you you can't
you will make yourself insane and you
will end up with a heart attack or a
stroke
um and or kids who are nervous to be
around you
or you can grieve it and that's the
dropping of your shoulders
and that's the screaming and being raged
out of god and being angry at what
happened and how slow the system is
and when those thoughts lightning bolt
into your head which they do and quite
honestly brother they will they're going
to
that's the moment
right when that thought comes into your
head the picture of that guy
the thought of that door slowly opening
in the dark and you see that crack and
you see that shadow of that guy standing
there because i know you've imagined it
when that goes into your head instantly
you can't help it when it does
that's when you've got a choice i will
not meditate on this
and the key is not just shutting that
thing down but it's having another
picture to replace it with
and so i would have pictures of my
daughter that make me laugh pictures
with my family that bring me joy
memories of times when we whatever
and i'm gonna make a conscious decision
every
single time that when that thought pops
into my head i'm gonna say the word out
loud nope
and i'm gonna have something else to
think on that brings me joy
and here's what's going to happen over
time
your brain is going to recognize this is
neuroscience that you my friend are
driving now
it doesn't have to default to the
automatic survival setting because you
are back in control
and it will dial down
the rage
right now it feels like that rage is
keeping you and your family safe and it
is not it's drowning everybody
will keep your family safe is a dad who
is fully present
who's not at peace with what happened
but is at peace with what comes next
okay you also cannot do this by yourself
and you may
it may be that you're in a situation
where traditional counseling might not
be your thing
do you have a group of guys that you
trust and can go get nachos and a beer
with and just be honest i'm just kind of
kind of struggling with that a little
bit because
historically speaking i've had my church
friends i've had my mma and jiu jitsu
friends i've had my law enforcement
friends my ems friends and they
typically don't interact or mingle with
each other i like to keep things
almost separate and so
mark stop trying to control everything
it doesn't work man it doesn't work
yeah
yeah
okay
you got kicked in the teeth hard man you
lost a bunch of teeth
and so now the question is what you can
do next you can go back to the gym
you're gonna say hey i'm not fighting
anymore it's fine
what am i gonna do um but i think
calling a group of guys and getting them
together
and just saying hey this happened
and i'm just sick about it and i just
need to tell a group of guys that i love
yeah it's the word that nobody wants to
hear nobody wants to use especially
tough guys
um like you and i but you gotta have to
be vulnerable you gotta roll over and
say i got hurt and somebody hurt my most
prized possession
you're gonna have to say that out loud
to other people
and that's part of the healing process i
wish i knew how to give you a pill to
make that not the case but that is the
case
on the other side of grief
and on the other side you'll still get
mad mad mad you will get angry angry
angry the difference will be that you
won't feel trapped
and your body won't be enraged
you'll be mad and pissed off like you
should be
and he won't get the sentence that you
think he should unless some people come
forward i'll also challenge you the same
way i challenged her your 13 year old
doesn't get very many votes in this one
yeah okay and i know that that's hard
and i know that's quote unquote not cool
and you're gonna feel like you're
re-traumatizing her whatever right now
she needs parents who a believe her and
b are willing to say
i know this is what you think you want
but you're a child and we're going to be
in your corner
yeah okay
and that's super hard
have you heard my analogy about the
twin towers
no
so
i heard it from a
one of my favorite therapists who was
talking about
rebuilding a marriage after infidelity
and here's and it works across the board
so i'll give it to you
with the understanding that the greatest
gift you could give your children right
now all five of them
is to heal your marriage
and to heal and to grieve
by yourself and together okay
um
she said that
you could never go back to
downtown new york
and sweep up all the steel and ash and
dust and broken glass and use all of
that to re those materials to rebuild
the twin towers they have fallen
the only choices you have are to a walk
away
and leave it in rubble
or
hire a couple of contractors get some
construction crews down there and
excavate the entire site
and then go sit with some architects and
some engineers and some artists and
reimagine and rebuild something arguably
more beautiful
structurally stronger
that's a monument to the past but is
ocho a
clear directive for what comes next
and so we're not trying to get back to
what was we are trying to build
something that will be
and you what that looks like in real
life is you and your wife go take a half
day retreat or y'all get out of town
and you for the first time weep
not from a place of anger or rage or
control but from a place of grief
and you'll write letters to eat all five
of your daughters you dream about what
could be
where you all want to live what you want
to do all of those things you talk about
what you need and what she needs from
you and what you need from her
and y'all recommit to
practicing the things every day
see what i'm saying we're rebuilding the
whole thing from the floor up this is
just what happened this is where we are
the towers fell yeah
a lot of wasted energy and a lot of
wasted anger and rage are in trying to
preserve what was what was is no more
this happened
can i tell you this
what's up
um
your daughter is
lucky he's all bloody hell that she has
you as her old man
and i'm telling you that after talking
to thousands of dad over the last two
dads or the last two decades
she won the absolute lottery getting you
and it's time for you to understand and
believe that
you're a good man mark
you're a good dad
thanks
okay
my commitment to you is i'll be with you
every step of the way call anytime
do i have your commitment that you're
not gonna do something stupid you're not
gonna hurt anybody
yeah i'm not gonna do anything okay as
much as i want to but i know
the one thing i want you to commit to
doing is
not committing to trying to fight back
the rage moving forward i want your
commitment to be i'm gonna heal and i'm
gonna grieve like crazy
and then my wife and i are gonna
re-imagine what comes next and then
we're gonna be about building that with
our five daughters and that my friend is
shape shifter generational
change your family tree kind of stuff
and by the way
at some point on the back end of grief
there's making meaning of this madness
and making meaning might look like you
rejoin the police force and join a task
force or you create a group of dads and
fathers or you go to the school board
and you get computers and screens out of
there because these kids are being
handed weapons of mass destruction and
they don't even know it
that you petition your local whatever
county to increase
the
you know penalties for fill in the blank
you run for public office i don't care
what it is but at some point
after you grieve this and you're able to
breathe and you're able to relax and
you'll be able to control the dial of
those thoughts you take control of those
thoughts
you begin to say okay what are we going
to do next how we've now found ourselves
way into the into the jungle
we've hacked our own path through here
how are we gonna invite people to walk
on this path with us now
i love you man i'm grateful for you
and
you're one of the strongest bravest men
i've talked to in a long long long time
and thank you for being honest with us
man and i'll keep walking alongside you